dan patrick show brought to you by
Continental Tire the exclusive tire the
Dan Patrick show no matter where you
drive what you drive continental designs
tires for what you do for more info
visit continental tire com continental
tire for what you do I imagine the
Cleveland Indians PR department said how
you got a phone call dan Patrick once to
have you on the show and terry francona
price said wait what did i do what did i
do wrong here and I thought no you
didn't do anything wrong it's just
always great to visit with Terry
Francona great season last year so skip
you didn't do anything wrong i'm just
saying it was i just wanted to reach out
and see how you're doing well that's
nice because a lot of times when i get
called in i always wonder still to this
day okay what I do or die mess well it's
nice to know that everything's
aboveboard did you get called in by the
Red Sox when they let you go like was it
a and in-person meeting or fungal oh boy
we had a lot of meetings like in the
short time we met we met quite a few
times over the course of a couple days
but they were always in person but I
don't I mean there may have been a phone
call but we were we were in person how
tough was the offseason what do you
replay in your mind just last offseason
yeah you know I had my hip replaced for
three or four days after the season so
there was probably a week that I
actually thought we won I mean I got I
got out of all my healers a parade um
you know what you never quite know what
your emotions are going to be till you
go through it and I guess that's the
good part you know back in two thousand
twelve when we lost the Tampa I was
devastated remember we won ten in a row
we're on you know we're on this great
streak and then Tampa beat us and two
and a half hours you have to the home
and really beat me up it took me a long
time to get rid of it well this year you
know the game's over you know you talk
to the team because you got to do that
and then you do your media obligations
now when I was finally by myself you
know you're disappointed because my
goodness you know you're trying to win
but I think pride one out quickly and I
really didn't have a hard time this one
I mean yeah you want to win I mean my
goodness but I was so proud of what our
guys accomplished that that's kind of
what one out and I'm not sure you can
really force that take me back to the
rain delay in Game seven but what do you
think and if there hadn't been that rain
delay how do you think this would have
played out you know it's interesting
because I mean I'm not sure it really
matters I mean you know whatever happens
whoever handles things better you know
has a better chance to win I've told a
lot of people i mean when Roger hit that
home run lesser teams would have lost
but the Cubs they deserve a lot of
credit I mean you know from all accounts
they they had a players-only whatever
they were doing in there but when they
came out they they they beat us we
didn't beat ourselves and they deserve a
lot of credit for that you know the one
thing that you know the first thing we
do on a rain delay is Mickey and I
pitching coach we look at our watches
and we checked the time and if there was
any pitcher that we were comfortable
having an it's brian shaw because he
bounces back so much and not much fuss
tourism they just came out and got hits
off of them and i give them credit for
that did you cross paths with kill
madden or a Theo Epstein in the
offseason you know what at that night
real late I was just like a member i was
telling you I was kind of by myself and
it was late and I was by myself and I
heard somebody yelling my name and it
was Theo and he had wandered over he was
in a suit and he was smelled like
champagne and he came over gave me a hug
and that's not the easiest thing to pull
off you know being the gracious winner
and he did and and I appreciated it and
you know again it did you know we got a
lot of history together and for him to
take the time to come over made me feel
good did it help and all that you had
one before well no not really I mean you
know I've always always think you stay
in the moment and you know the journey
you're on that's the one that you know
that's what counts and no I mean you
know we wanted to win it then this is a
you know this is I laugh when people say
hey is this one more special where's
that one more special
I mean the one you're doing right now
that's what's important and you know
heck yeah I want to win bad I just you
know this group we weren't very
experienced and going into playoffs
you're never quite sure how guys will
handle that but I thought has we got
confidence we we played better now we
showed our use at times but I don't know
how else you know we work on useful
we're talking to Terry Francona and
Cleveland Indians manager what do you
think of GM's in the Hall of Fame what
do I think yeah do you think that there
should be G&I yeah I'm getting around
his field Epstein a Hall of Famer oh boy
you know what I I don't know if I've
ever really thought about it I mean the
hall of fame is for baseball people that
you know doux-doux people other people
hbu as Hall of Fame caliber so I would
say definitely let me shoot thats that's
uh that doesn't seem like a real tough
one yeah I didn't know like Pat Gillick
I thought is you know it's a great GM
Hall of Famer Bob Howsam with the
Cincinnati Reds the Big Red Machine I
think there are certain GM's I just
don't know if they get enough credit but
feoo i agree i definitely agree where
your goal of that I think you know but
and I think I think what's so what's so
special about Cooper's down is that you
go up there and you'll see announcers
writers yeah baseball players yeah heck
yeah I think that if you're associated
with baseball and people think that
you're you've made that kind of a career
I think it's great and a couple other
things the intentional walk rule yay or
nay you know what I'm okay I don't think
it's I don't think it's as big a deal as
people making it out I I don't know that
it's also going to save the game as much
time as they're looking for you know
it's it i think we walked I think
somebody on the average of once every
eight or nine games if I had my druthers
I would have probably kept it but I
think there's probably bigger arguments
to pick than that that's it's okay what
would be the bigger ones well I mean
just like I said just doesn't seem like
it's that big a deal you know I do think
they could like they're doing a good
thing this year with the you know
with the replay you know they're going
to make managers make a decision in 30
seconds if you want to replay I think
that's going to definitely cut into you
know a lot of wasted time and so I think
that's a good thing and and when we were
going over this at the beginning they
didn't know if they were going to do
that so I think they made a really good
move there if we if we can't make a
decision in 30 seconds maybe we
shouldn't be reviewing it because you
know it was put in for the i think the
word day is a big word to big adjective
uh not gregarious but was Larry igri
grieves me to agree thank you thank you
egregious calls and you know if you're
sometimes you wait and wait wait you see
a guy pop up off the bag on a stolen
base that's not what it was put in for
so if you can't judge in 30 seconds
maybe y'all just leave alone here is
another thing I don't know if baseball
doing a great job in promoting its stars
I know I know locally regionally it
feels like they do but what white we
don't know much about Mike Trout what
why I do i I don't know but he's the
best player in the game right I mean
he's one of them that's for damn sure
okay but it feels like we don't know
baseball players the way we used to and
we know you 98 there's no I get that you
know what though in there I game I hear
people say that all the time you know i
do think baseball is still the one sport
is probably a regional you know regional
game I mean people follow their home
team and you know i don't i don't know
because I don't sit and think about how
we market MLB I know there's people
smarter than me they're getting paid to
do it you know whether we're doing a
good enough job I don't know but I do
think it's a regional game more than the
other sports because we know Bryce
Harper but we know I'm kind of because
of his look he's got some style about
him but when people talk about Jose
Altuve like nobody knows who
a lot of these guys are whereas it used
to be when we were growing up you knew
those baseball players we knew all about
them I don't I don't know who the blame
goes to but it feels help and yet then
maybe it's not blame maybe it's just
that you know times have changed and you
know there's you know there's so much to
offer now I mean you know football has
gone crazy you know it's such a popular
sport on television the NBA I mean
there's all kinds of things going on and
ain't no baseball place every single day
so you're gonna get the local stuff but
the national you know there's not a game
but there's not that the Saturday game
of the week anymore with tony kubek and
Kirk out and you know there's games on
every night regionally and then some
nights yes PNR somebody will have helped
but you'll have a game that's a national
game but it's mostly regional but do you
think if we speed up the game all of a
sudden people are going to care about
the game more and then there's therefore
therefore going to invest in some of you
know these stars I don't know what comes
first the chicken or the egg here no and
that's a good point i do think what i
think what they're trying to do is to
when the casual fans come to a game
maybe want them to come back and i get
that that makes me at me i mean shoot I
you know I don't think they're trying to
the one thing I will say is like when
Joe Torre and that group of guys comes
through to talk about rule changes I
know Jim Leyland on that committee they
really take pains and time to explain it
and they don't ever want to mess because
I have you know the people that like
myself is betting this game forever it's
a beautiful game and when it's well
played it doesn't matter how much time
is spent but they're also trying to
attract younger people which I
understand and you know you're going to
get an argument both ways all the time
that's just the way it is before I let
you go did you ever have one of those
moments like Buck Showalter when buck
walk barry bonds with the bases loaded
did you ever have one of those moments
where you know people looked at the
strategy of it or did you ever think
about walking barry bonds with the bases
loaded
oh I thought about a lot of things um
you know I mean I mean you know like
with Andrew Miller last winter you know
youryour there's there's a fine line
between being smart and dumb and I'm
well aware of that if in that first game
against the res logic we lose that game
I would be still answering questions you
know why'd you use Andrew Miller what
you burned him he wasn't available but
for a hitter in the second game you know
you had use them like that all year
there's a fine line that's why I think
you know when it's all said and done you
got to know your guys you gotta you know
take the temperature your team and all
those things and do what you think is
right and then be confident enough to
answer the questions and move on because
that's what it is and there's a lot of
times I'll do the same thing two nights
in a row one night it works in one night
it doesn't but like I said just be
confident enough from what you're doing
and have a good reason for it answer the
questions and move on well Joe Maddon
almost it almost came back to haunt him
with Aroldis Chapman there because they
he he still you know people still kind
of hinting at that that he may have
almost screwed up the end and again
that's an upper jaws answer Joe's answer
as we one which is a really good because
they did if I just want the one thing I
will say is and let it managers are not
perfect by any means but I could never
manage another game like watch it now
stands or watch it on TV when you're in
the dugout with your guys you know
everything that's going on and you kind
of get like in that tunnel vision where
you know it's a good feeling like you
know you know what we're going to do
those always work but here's what we're
going to do if it doesn't work out
here's what we're going to go and again
it's the other thing we talked about all
the time is you want to have good common
sense well in the seventh eighth inning
sometimes it's hard to have common sense
that's why we talk about a lot of things
before the game starts and we'll talk to
you in the summer so I hope so yeah I
enjoy it so give me a holler I'd love to
catch up my buddy Matt so Terry Francona
take care man they like to call it is
the Indians manager
Patrick show weekday morning on audience